Jan Crawford has covered the Supreme
Court during much of Justice Kennedy's
tenant tenure Jan good morning president
Trump is now going to have the
conservative Supreme Court that
Republicans have dreamed of for a
lifetime does this mean that Roe vs.
Wade that grants abortion rights will be
doomed no and you know I mean President
Trump may have that Supreme Court
conservatives have dreamed about for a
lifetime because what I've learned from
covering the Supreme Court for the last
25 years is that conservative justices
tend to disappoint Republicans and the
Conservatives who try to put them on the
Supreme Court and they'll typically side
sometimes with liberals on social issues
just as Justice Kennedy did remember he
was nominated by President Reagan to say
that Roe versus Wade is in jeopardy I
think is overstating it right now we
don't know how the other justices and on
the conservative side would vote right
now on that justice Clarence Thomas is
the only justice on the Supreme Court
who has said he would overturn it it
could well be considered settled law but
what I do think you're going to see is
the next justice kind of putting the
brakes on further development extending
these rights whether it's abortion
rights affirmative action or gay rights
kind of put the brakes on some of those
developments so Jan what do we know
about who the president is considering
for the next nominee well yeah I mean he
has a long list of potential contenders
for this seat but I think there are
really three primary frontrunners right
now they're all federal appeals court
judges they have sterling academic
credentials that's Brett Kavanaugh
Raymond Catholic and Amul sipar the part
is interesting because he would be the
first Indian American on the Supreme
Court and he's also a prodigy of said at
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell so I
think you're gonna kind of see this
McConnell is gonna be pushing for him
you're gonna have some people inside the
White House in the White House counsel's
office who are really pushing for judge
Cavanaugh any women on the shortlist
there are I mean there's one I think we
really could take a look at and they're
considering to bring in for an interview
with the President and that's Amy Kony
Barrett she's a former Notre Dame law
professor recently confirmed to the
federal appeals court so she may be kind
of in waiting for that next nomination
because remember two of these
this is on the Supreme Court right now
are going to be over 80 years old this
year and they're both liberals justice
ginsburg's 85 all right Jen Crawford for
us at the Supreme Court Thank You Jen